hi good afternoon everyone i am
absolutely delighted to invite you all
to our monthly convening of the
inference colloquium series today we
have an exciting talk from one of the
core members of our interdisciplinary
team dr janan ismail who is a
pre-eminent philosopher of science and
on the faculty at columbia university
but before i introduce her more formally
i would first like to thank mr and mrs
richard and barbara frankie for their
generosity and support of yale's
flagship interdisciplinary program the
frankie program in science and
humanities and many other activities at
yale
i think they were planning to join us
here today so welcome um i would like to
remind you all that as we are recording
this event and therefore all
participants must mute their videos
if you wish uh please go ahead and
submit your questions through the chat
feature per custom
thai dr thai camp and i will be
monitoring the chat and we'll read out
the questions after the talk in the q a
session
so on to our speaker today
professor janan ismail joined the
faculty at columbia university in 2018
and most of her research work falls into
sort of two sort of classes two big sets
of questions
the first is
circumscribes the central concerns of
philosophy of physics
and in that realm her interests include
the structure of space and time the
foundations of quantum mechanics the
role of simplicity and symmetry in
physics questions about the nature of
probability natural laws and causal
relations
so as you can see all rather big and
important very significant foundational
questions
and the second set of interests include
mind cognition phenomenology and the
nature of perspectives janan received
her phd from princeton university was a
melon fellow at stanford after that and
then taught at the university of arizona
before coming to colombia
she is the recipient of many honors and
awards and i will just mention a few um
she has held several prestigious
fellowships including an neh fellowship
at the national humanities center
queen elizabeth ii research fellowship
from the australian research council and
fellowships from the templeton
foundation and the center for advanced
studies and behavioral science at
stanford
and i'm also delighted to let you all
know that her conversant at the
discussion session tomorrow which will
start at the same time is professor jim
woodward who is a distinguished
professor in the department of history
and philosophy of science at the
university of pittsburgh and i will tell
you more about him tomorrow and before
turning over the floor to janaan i would
like to remind
you of some of our ongoing and
forthcoming projects um at the frankie
program i would particularly like to
mention the learning by doing project
which is a collection of simple videos
for
children to teach them how science works
and the set of upcoming inference
project talks
uh so our next inference uh project talk
will be in october uh by brian cantwell
smith
and uh
meanwhile with the frankie program we
have a distinguished speaker series
talks by jordan ellenberg in early
october october 6th and by hazel carvey
uh on november 3rd
uh so anyway without further ado uh once
again a warm welcome to you all and to
you janaan and to jim
uh janan the floor is yours
uh thanks so much for having me and
special thanks um to jim woodward for
agreeing to um be the conversant
tomorrow
so let me just
so there's been an
kind of enormous burgeoning of interest
in causation across the sciences and the
details of various kinds are easy to
locate so one can open up a journal in
microbiology
and be assailed with detailed models of
the causal structure of cells and
proteins
one can find textbooks on the increasing
array of computational tools for causal
search and discovery and take classes
devoted to for example formal methods
and causal modeling
psychologists are unraveling new details
about how people use causal concepts in
reasoning
and while the tales of these kinds
are in abundant supply it's not easy to
find among them
an answer to the question of what
causation is or how it fits into
[Music]
a physics-based ontology
so i'm going to try to fill that hole by
assembling the pieces
of our understanding emerging scientific
understanding of causation into an
account of where
and how causation arises in the
architecture of the physical world with
special attention to the contested
questions of where the direction
of causation comes from
is connection to the second law of
thermodynamics
and the relationship between causation
and agency
so if you've been attending other talks
in this series
um you'll have heard about some of these
things what i
um say will have the most in common with
carlo rivelli's beautiful talk which
opened the series with maybe a little
more focused attention on the
philosophical questions
so this will sort of bring things back
around full circle
i'm going to adopt a very high level
perspective kind of pulling our gaze
away
from details to try to pull the big
pieces into place to get an overall view
of the whole vista
so if one looks back
at the early history of science it can
be seen
as developing out of systematization and
abstraction of causal thinking the
search for an understanding of the
causal relations among events
that is as true of physics as it is of
the other sciences so i think it's not
wrong to say as russell bertrand russell
did in 1955
that the aim of physics consciously or
unconsciously has always been to
discover what we may call the causal
skeleton
of the world
now at first the notion of cause
retained its close connection with
mechanical ideas so a cause was
something that brought about its effect
by a transfer
of force
but by the time newton had finished with
it causation didn't appear
in the final presentation of his own
theory at all
what he put in the place of causal
relations are mathematical equations
oops sorry
mathematical equations usually expressed
in the form of differential equations
that give the rate of change of a
quantity over time
causes and the associated idea of force
dropped out of the final presentation
entirely there's no direction and
there's no asymmetry of determination
later events determine earlier ones as
surely as earlier ones determine later
ones
and it's clear from the quote that i
just said about um earlier from russell
that russell actually came around to
thinking quite differently
but 32 years earlier he wrote in a paper
on the notion of cause that's the
starting point of all
almost every discussion of causation and
physics
now in that paper russell noted that the
kinds of laws that newtonian mechanic
gives us are so different from causal
relations as traditionally conceived
that's misleading to think of them in
causal terms at all
and he urged that sorry i keep doing
this sorry
he urged
that causation is a folk notion that has
no place in immature science
the modern discussion of causation and
the philosophy of science really began
after russell was cartwright's deeply
influential critique
of russell's paper and what cartwright
pointed out was that dynamical laws
can't play the role of causal relations
in science because specifically causal
information is needed to distinguish
effective from ineffective strategies
for bringing about ants
so for example it might be true
as a matter of law
because smoking causes bad breath that
there's a strong positive correlation
between bad breath and cancer but it is
not true that brad breath causes cancer
and hence it's not true that treating
bad breath is an effective strategy for
preventing cancer
and that difference the difference
between being correlated with cancer
and being a way of bringing it about is
not one that can be captured by looking
at only at the dynamical laws
so if one wants to avoid getting cancer
one has to know not simply what cancer
is correlated with as a matter of
physical law but what causes it that is
what brings it about
so this was cartwright's observation and
it led to a lot of handwringing
wondering what causal information adds
to the kind of global dynamical laws
that russell took as paradigmatic the
physical laws
and philosophers played around a little
bit with probably probabilistic and
counterfactual analyses and there were a
lot of unresolved questions about the
metaphysics of causal relations
one strand in contemporary discussion
followed russell in denying that physics
has any real place for causation and
continued to reject causal talk as
anything
but folk physics
now in the last 15 years or so however
there's been a real revolution in our
understanding of causal thinking
stemming from a lot allied developments
in a coalition of fields from computer
science to psychology
and it was really
the structural causal modeling framework
from pearl and um sort of parallel
developments and spurtees gleemorn
shyness
and its philosophical development by jim
woodward that transformed the discussion
so what the framework does is it gives
us a precise formal framework for
representing causal relationships that's
well suited to causal search and
discovery in science it's been at the
center of developments and causal
learning and
statistical inference it can be used to
define normative solutions to causal
inference and judgment problems it
facilitated new insights into the role
of causal thinking and cognition
the influence and the power of that
framework are undisputed and largely due
to its utility in concrete science in
raising concrete scientific questions
that can be
investigated in the laboratory
from a philosophical point of view what
it's done is helped us resolve i think
the puzzle brought out by the exchange
between russell and cartwright that is
the disappearance of causes from the
fundamental level of
physical description on the one hand and
their indispensability and practical
reasoning on the other
and the way that it resolves the puzzle
is by giving us an articulated
understanding of where and how causation
or better causal thinking and the
structures that support causal thinking
arise in the architecture of the cosmos
and in the way that is characteristic of
philosophical questions once they pass
into the hands of the sciences
is transformed some of the old questions
while also raising new ones
so just to highlight a few feature
relevant features of the formalism so
type causation is basic that is
causation between types of events
and it's relative to networks so type
causation relates types of events like
the striking of a match of a specified
kind under under given circumstances
rather than the particular striking of a
particular match at a particular time
and place
and this accords well with science
because
with practice and science because
scientists to a large part devoted to
the identification of type causal
relationships
networks are defined by collections of
variables individual properties are
represented by the values of variables
the choice of which variables to include
and which to leave out of a network when
studying a causal claim make a
difference to whether there is a causal
link between a pair of variable
variables and what the link is
singular causal claims so like the claim
that a dot on a photographic plate was
caused by the impact of an electron
those are derived from type causation
dags this is just again introducing
relevant features of the formalism
dags directed acyclic graphs are used to
represent causal relations among
variables in a network so direct
causation is represented by an arrow
and it's the most basic causal relation
in a network a variable
x i for example is a direct cause of
another variable x j relative to a set
of variables v
just in case there's an in just in case
there is an intervention on the first
that will change the value of the second
or change the probability distribution
over values of the second when all of
the variables in the network in question
except those two are held fixed
so dags these diagrams give us a
prespicuous way of displaying causal
relationships
an example like this you can see
immediately how intervening on one
variable will affect other variables in
the network
now from the point of view
of this framework causal judgments in
everyday contexts rely on loose and
tacit assumptions about which variables
are being considered what's being held
fixed in situ for the purposes of
assessing the effects of one variable
and another those choices are made
explicit in the formalization
and because it makes them explicit it
lets us separate the objective content
of causal claims from the sort of loose
context dependent pragmatic factors that
guide the choice of the network
so the question that comes
out of the russell cartwright exchange
was
how does causal information
recall go beyond the information
captured in dynamical laws that is what
does causal information add to those
laws or if it doesn't add anything what
information contained in those laws
does it make explicit
so here's the way to think of it
global dynamical laws
the kinds of laws that newton's theory
gave us
give us information about the
relationships between global states at
different times
causal information
is information about the results of
hypothetical interventions whereby that
we mean in questions about what would
happen if a variable were separated from
its earlier history and allowed to vary
freely
now the difficulty of
with extracting causal information from
global dynamical laws is that the global
dynamical laws don't allow the
separation of a variable from its own
past clauses
so here's an example suppose someone
presents you with something like this a
schematized model of an engine for a car
has a collection of components
a piston an engine block a timing chain
a crankshaft and so on now the parts
move
but so long as they're assembled in the
form of an engine
they they have a restricted range of
motion relative to one another so if we
model the engine
we model the engine at the level of
description that treats these functional
components as basic parts we can come up
with dynamical equations that would
describe how the global state of the
engine
varies over time and those dynamical
equations
for the engine would tell you that
there's a fixed relationship with for
example the pistons and the valve
so given the equations you could use the
position of one of those things
to calculate the position of the other
so maybe when one is up the other is
down when the other is down the other
one is up
they move but they move together
and if you just look at the okay the
equations there would be three causal
hypotheses that you might
come up with
one is that the position of a causes the
position of b
that the position of b causes the
position of a or that they have a common
cause now remember the global dynamical
equations just fix the relative values
of a
and b
these three hypotheses however
have different modal implications so if
a causes b
then if you kept everything else fixed
and you reached in
and you moved a up and down
you should be able to see b move as well
so that's what you would be committed to
if you asserted that a causes b
if b causes a
then the other thing holds you should be
able to reach in
um and move b keeping everything else
fixed and a should move if the two have
a common cause then neither of these
infamous interventions should affect the
value of the other
since the common cause c
would be left unaffected and it's the
thing that causes both okay
now in the case of
an open system like a car engine
interventions from the outside
are physically realizable and often in a
way that serves to effectively separate
the variable from its own past causes
inside the system of interest
i'll say a little bit more about this
below but what the example here does is
it makes the logical point that how that
that the dynamical equations for the
engine of um as a whole don't tell you
which of these hypotheses are correct
because the counter factuals that you
need to discriminate between these
hypotheses
between the three causal hypotheses
here
namely what would happen if we could
hold everything else fixed and intervene
from the outside to alter the variable
of one of the values in the network
those counterfactuals are physically
impossible there is no model of the
engine as a whole compatible with its
global dynamical laws
in which the antecedents of those
counterfactuals
is realized
so if the engine comprised the universe
as a whole and the global equations were
all that we had
then there would be no way of discerning
the underlying causal structure
of the engine
just by looking at the dynamical laws
the reason
is not that it the reason that that is
is not that information that we is not
that the information that we can extract
from global laws
um it's not that the laws don't have
modal content is that the modal content
that they have
is global so global laws will tell us
what kinds of worlds are possible
but they don't tell us what would happen
if we would if we could intervene on one
of those worlds in a way that's contrary
to law
so in logical terms we would say the
antecedents to intervention
counterfactuals
are numerologically impossible that is
they're contrary to law
so if we take the global laws as more
basic we don't generally get
causal information
so that tells us something about in
terms of the content of causal claims
what distinguishes them from what we can
get out of global dynamical laws but it
gives rise
to another question and the question is
how is causal knowledge possible
at our world
if causal information is information
about what would happen if some variable
were separated from its past causes and
allowed to vary freely
and in fact no variable is ever actually
separated from its past causes how could
we study
causal structure
and the answer is that in practical
terms there are various ways of
effectively randomizing the values of
the variable which provides a separation
and effective separation from its own
past causes so that we can treat changes
to the values of that variable as
interventions so for example flip a coin
have a random number generator set the
value for um the variable you want to
intervene on let a lab assistant choose
one at will
any variable that can be manipulated
and whose own causes are uncorrelated
with the variables of interest that that
is the variables whose um on who on
which
the causal impact of the variable that
you're intervening on
is the one that you're interested in can
be regarded for such purposes as
external to the system
and changes in the value of such
variables can be regarded as
interventions
this of course is the essence of
scientific
experimentation the possibility of
knowledge of causal knowledge rests on
the fact that we can effectively isolate
systems in the laboratory manipulate the
external input to them and observe the
impacts of our manipulations
and this in its turn tells us something
important
about how we should think of the
metaphysics of causation or better i
would say the physical substructure that
supports causal belief
and it's this
in a world that is as complicated as
ours and which decomposes
into a collection of rule-governing
components
where the laws governing configurations
can be given in terms of the law's
governing components and their
interactions
causal information can be extracted from
the laws governing components
and the interactions
one can concoct very simple examples
sorry of very simple worlds or worlds in
which there are nonlogical restrictions
that is law-like restrictions
on initial conditions in which causal
information cannot be extracted from the
global laws
but what's really going on
is that in those worlds the global
dynamical laws will not allow us to
recover laws governing components
and interactions
so long as one is willing to take the
local nomological structure of the world
that as basic
one can ground facts about the results
of hypothetical interventions in that
structure that is to say in the laws
that govern the components deriving the
global laws from restrictions on
configurations of components
and indeed that's that follows the
standard practice in physics so when you
learn newtonian physics for example you
learn that an object will not change its
motion unless a force acts on it that
the force on an object is equal to the
mass its mass times the acceleration and
that when two objects interact they
exert forces on one another of equal
magnitude in opposite direction so what
you learn is really the laws governing
the components
you piece together an understanding of
the equations of motion for the universe
as a whole
from an understanding of what its parts
are and the laws that govern the
components so i think it's a sort of
perversion of the content of physical
theories to make a lunge for the global
laws
and then insist that the full modal
content of the theory has to be somehow
extractable from the form that they take
for a world for our world for the
particular configurations of components
that makes up our world
now the relations captured in dags
those interventionist causal
relationships
are experimentally accessible
they're often first in the order of
discovery they're part of the surface
fabric of the world and almost taylor
fit to play the role that cartwright
highlighted when she argued for the
indispensability of causal relations
in practical reasoning
but there's another tradition that comes
out of the later russell in this case by
way of the philosophers reichenbach and
nathan
sorry wesley salmon
and that receives its fullest
development in phil dao's work and this
tradition
analyzes causal relations in terms of
what he calls causal processes
so causal processes are chains of events
that are related by interactions where a
causal interaction is an interaction
between
events
or
objects that involves a local exchange
of a conserved quantity
causal processes can be defined more
directly in terms of micro dynamical
laws so causal process
so this is a way of trying to introduce
a causal notion that one could connect
more directly to the sorts of dynamical
laws that are given by newtonian physics
causal process and interventionist
accounts are sometimes treated as
competing accounts of causation but we
don't need to choose between them
they're both useful and in classical
physics we find interpretations or
examples of both interventionist causal
relationships and causal processes in
the in the dao tradition
we have causal processes at the
fundamental level and we have the kind
of manipulable causal relationships
captured by dags
all over the place
these relationships are undiscriminating
about levels they're neutral about
underlying processes they represent
often local scaffolded relations among
variables that can be investigated
experimentally frequently without
knowledge of the underlying processes
both moreover that is both the
relationships captured by dags and
causal processes both of those notions
capture some aspects of our everyday
notion
of cause the interventionist relate
notion captures the idea that you have a
causal connection when one thing can be
used to bring about another
causal processes on the other hand
capture the idea that influences
propagate through space causal
influences propagate through space and
that they satisfy the expectation that
causal connections should be mediated by
mechanisms and that they involve some
sort of contact some sort of local
bumping up against one another
so if cause if interventionist causal
relationships are part of the surface
fabric of the world then you can think
of causal processes as part of the deep
theoretically postulated substructure
that supports the high-level
relationships captured by dags
so i said um that classical physics
gives us both causal processes and the
high-level causal networks captured by
dags but there's a puzzle about the
relationship between the sort of
high-level causal pathways and the
underlying dynamical processes that's
crucial to understanding causal notions
of both kinds
so interventionist causal relationships
of the kind captured in dags have one
striking future
they're temporarily asymmetric so they
run in one direction from past to future
and that temporal asymmetry is no mere
matter of convention if we follow
cartwright in saying that what's
definitive of causal relationships as
distinct from mere probabilistic
correlations
is that they can function as strategic
routes to bringing about ends then it's
manifest and pervasive empirical fact
about our world that all known strategic
routes to bringing about ends
run from past the future
so janan if i may have to have a quick
question
so in the absence of micro physical laws
does it mean that causation is not well
defined or it cannot be established
so i'm thinking of something like
gravity right so you do not have
microphysical laws
and um yeah so i'm curious is that um
in the previous slide
you had that as one of the points
the causal pro that's true of causal
processes i see uh newtonian mechanics
so you're right neutron mechanics
there's no mechanism for the propagation
of gravitational influence and that's
right so according to causal process
accounts there's no causal
link between um
so there's no causal mechanism or causal
process by which gravitational influence
is propagated
uh thank you
it's a good question thank you for that
okay so
so let me go back
to
okay
um
so as i'm saying that the temporal
asymmetries no matter is no matter of
convention and indeed of all of the
reasons that russell gave in that early
paper for saying that causation had been
purged from physics at the fundamental
level this is the one that persuaded
most people the underlying dynamical
laws are simply equations of motion that
relate the state of the universe at one
time to have stated the others they have
no intrinsic direction
of determination
so they couldn't in that sense be
properly called causes okay
so now this gives rise to a
straightforward physical puzzle however
how do the kinds of high-level causal
pathways that i've said are an objective
part of the surface fabric of our world
arise from temporally symmetric
underlying laws
now this isn't the kind of question that
people in the lab studying signal
pathways and cells and so on typically
ask
scientists who empirically investigate
the causal structure who in sorry who
empirically investigate causal structure
of particular kinds of systems
take it for granted that causal
relations run from past to future so
they set up experiments that allow
localized interventions and they look
for the temporally downstream
effects
but it is a theoretical question for the
physicist
trying to relate the kinds of causal
pathways studied in for example biology
labs to an underlying theory
and as it happens it's a question that's
been illuminated by research into the
foundations
of thermodynamics so for those of you
who don't know the history that research
began in mid-19th century and it was
originally focused on trying to derive
the phenomenological asymmetries
embodied in the second law of
thermodynamics from time symmetric laws
of classical mechanics and it turned
only quite recently into a very general
account
of the sources of temporal asymmetry in
our world so a conversation that started
by being about why for example a gas
will disperse to fill an open container
but not collect spontaneously
in one corner or why ice melts when when
placed in a warm glass of water but we
don't see ice cubes spontaneously form
out of warm water without a change in
temperature
how that turned into a conversation
about why for example we remember the
past but not the future and why time
seems to flow from past to future and
why causation doesn't run backwards
and as in the revolution in our thinking
about causation that i said came with
the development of the structural causal
modeling framework there was input from
both scientists and philosophers that
was sort of instrumental to the
development so for example there was
boltzmann maxwell and gibbs all
scientists but there was also
reichenbach david albert hugh price all
of course
philosophers so there remains a lot of
dispute in the foundations of
thermodynamics and dispute in particular
about how to understand some of the most
important philosophically important
temporal asymmetries but it was really
david albert's account from this this
book in 2000 that brought the
foundations of thermodynamics into the
kind of conceptual focus that made it
possible to really attack
these questions so albert's account
that is the philosophically interesting
temporary symmetries so albert's account
has three first principles there's the
newtonian laws of motion there's a
statistical postulate and there's
something that he calls the past
hypothesis
so here's how it works newtonian laws of
motion are just the familiar time
symmetric laws that russell was
referring to
the statistical postulate is a
probability distribution that assigns a
probability distribution to a system
being in a given microstate
given its macro state
macrostate is just given by the values
of thermodynamic parameters
it's just the statistical posture
there's a strict addition to the laws so
it doesn't follow from them directly
though there are a lot of attempts to
motivate it dynamically
the past hypothesis the third of these
postulates
is a contingent hypothesis about the
early history of the world it says that
the universe started in a state of low
enough entropy to make thermodynamic
generalizations applicable for the
roughly 15 billion years that we think
that those generalizations have hold
have held and here's how the account
goes the three postulates work together
as follows newtonian dynamical laws
delimit the space of physically possible
worlds the past hypothesis knocks out
all of those worlds that don't start out
in a low entropy state
and then if you take the initial
microstates of the remaining worlds and
you apply the newtonian mechanical
dynamical laws you will see that some of
those remaining worlds will be on what
are called entropy increasing
trajectories that's that is to say that
their entropy will be increasing from
that initial state over its history
until it reaches equilibrium and some of
them will be on entropy decreasing
trajectories that is where the entropy
will decrease from the initial state as
far as the dynamical laws go there will
be worlds of both kinds and the
remaining set the statistical postulate
then will enter in and provide a
probability distribution over the worlds
that overwhelmingly favors those on
entropy increasing trajectories okay so
the result of these three things
is that the most probable and not just
the most probable but the overwhelmingly
most probable history of the universe is
one wherein entropy rises
now albert himself gives the account at
the global level where i mean he he
he presents it in exactly the way that i
just said that you have a probability
distribution over worlds and um and you
apply
the the whole account at the level of
worlds as a whole
one need not do that
formally it works just as well for some
local adiabatically isolated subsystem
of the world that is a system that's not
exchanging energy with its environment
and indeed there are good reasons for
thinking that that that the story might
best be told at that level
why because those are the systems to
which thermodynamics is typically
applied
and second it's not obvious whether the
local story follows from the global one
i think it does but it's not it's not as
perspicuous as if you give the story
directly at the local level and finally
the probabilities have a much clearer
interpretation if the story is told at
the local level okay
so if you look at albert's postulates
the newtonian laws
are time symmetric they run
the the there is no direction of
determination built in to them and the
statistical postulate is also time
independent so the only time asymmetric
assumption
is the past hypothesis okay you know
that the the initial state of the world
was low entropy but there's no
corresponding
boundary condition
in the future
and it's a particularly crucial part of
the story because it's doing all of the
explanatory work in terms of deriving
the um the
temporal asymmetries okay
um there's been some important
discussion about the right form for that
hypothesis everybody agrees that some
kind of temporal asymmetry and boundary
conditions is needs to be assumed to
extract the temporal asymmetries of
thermodynamics in albert's account it's
low entropy state for the universe at
some time in assistant past
matthias fresh in a discussion of the
asymmetries embodied in causal reasoning
has shown that there are different ways
of expressing the time asymmetric
assumptions that are needed to generate
the sorts of asymmetries that would
support causal inferences so he points
out that it would do just as well for
example to assume a causal markov
condition that is that any node in a dag
is conditionally independent of its
non-decent non-descendants given its
parents or as an assumption about of
microscopic randomness in the initial
but not final state of a system
i think there's no substantive question
about which of these assumptions is more
fundamental you can derive them from one
another there are different ways of
describing the structures that that is
to say the contingent asymmetries in our
world that support causal inferences
running from past to future
others have pointed out that in the
explanatory story what's really needed
to generate thermodynamic
generalizations is not really an initial
low entropy but the randomness or
uniformity of the early
universe that matters so while there's a
lot sort of to
sort out here what there is is broad
agreement that pending the mathematical
conjectures on which this account rests
the local macroscopic asymmetries in our
part of the universe
have their origin and the fact about the
state of our universe in the distant
past that developed under effectively
classical laws into a world with the
sorts of emergent macroscopic
asymmetries
captured in thermodynamic
generalizations
now if one is interested
in how this story connects specifically
to causal inference one will be
interested in
in in
some
sort of different ways of stating the
assumptions that are needed to derive
the asymmetries
if one's more interested in cartwright's
idea
that if you're given a body of
correlations the causal pathways are the
ones that can be used as strategic
groups to bring bad ends
here's how to get that in a way that
connects more naturally to that idea
okay
so this is a conception of causation
that brings
um the connection to agency into the
foreground and connects to people's
pre-theoretic idea that causation is
something that you can use to bring
about
ends
if we start
in a world with the thermodynamic
gradient
and we hold fixed all of the information
embodied in the present survivable
macroscopic state of the world so the
kind of information that an agent has
just by looking around her and here i
don't mean just what you get by looking
around you and holding fix the ambient
temperature and dispositions of
medium-sized dry goods i mean you hold
fixed all of the information embodied in
libraries scientific databases all of
the information that we've somehow
amassed and recorded or that we could
have accessed and recorded and we ask
what's the probabilistic effect holding
all of that fixed of local interventions
on the present state of the environment
of a kind that are possible in practical
terms for agents like us so you
manipulate some future
of your local environment
and you apply the probability postulate
to obtain a probability distribution
over the possible microstate
of the world
and then you evolve that forward or
backward in time
using the classical mechanical laws
here's what happens if you're just
evolving it forward or backward with the
classical micro-mechanical laws you
can't really predict much about either
the past or the future why because
there are lots of different ways that
the world could be everything depends on
the actual microstate of the universe
and you don't need to just know what's
going on locally microscopically here
you need to know what's going on
everywhere
you need the microstate of the universe
as a whole to predict anything with the
classical laws
if however we conditionalize
on the low entropy
state in the distant past then the
probabilities of past events
of which we have any kind of macroscopic
record
will be unaltered but the intervention
will raise the probability of certain
kinds of macroscopic future events okay
now the backward part
of this that is the question of what
makes something a record and the reason
that conditionalizing under low entropy
past makes the macroscopic present full
of records that's something that's been
extensively studied so if you went to
carla rivelli's talk for example the
first that the first in the series that
i mentioned he did a beautiful job of
making explicit the physics of that but
the way to think of it and and
well i'm
the
and the way that one has to think
there's a little bit more that needs to
be added here which is that one has to
think of the internal one has to think
in a certain way of the internal
dynamics of the agent right but what i'm
trying to show you is how all of these
pieces together fit together
conceptually at the macro scale to help
us understand causation and the way to
think of it
um to get the causal stuff into it is
that the causal asymmetry is really the
flip side of the asymmetry of records
so when you intervene in the local
environment there will be traces in the
future
of your intervention
and when you it's it's what you what
you'll be doing is you'll be doing some
work you jump into a swimming pool you
leave a footprint in the sand you dig a
ditch or you build a house and what
you're doing from a physical perspective
is you're creating an ordered state of
the environment that will take some time
to decay
so what you think of as the effects of
your action are the future records of
its occurrence
that means if we look for the strategic
routes for bringing about ends if we
look for ways of doing something in the
here and now that will make a difference
to probabilities of future events of
probabilities of events at other times
and places we will find that there's
nothing that one can do to make a
difference to the past
but there's a lot that we can do to make
a difference to the future
so the causal asymmetry
is just the flip side of the asymmetry
of records what you're doing when you
act in the in the here and now is you're
creating future records of your present
action
now so far everything that i've said
stays at the level of physical structure
we've talked about the temporally
symmetric laws about the ace asymmetric
interventionist pathways that can be
studied in the lab and captured in dags
we have the external infrastructure in
place that describes the macroscopic
fabric of the world
now we're in a position to talk about
causal concepts
so we've moved from talking about
structure in the world
that is struck external infrastructure
in the in the environment to talking
about something that has a role in an
agent's internal cognitive economy
okay
to do that
we need to introduce an agent
and we couple the agent to the
macroscopic structure of the world
what is an agent an agent is the system
whose job it is to extract information
from the environment
and use it to guide behavior
it is coupled to the world via sensory
and motor pathways that give it
macroscopic information
and sensory feedback
on its own interventions
and so now
we ask how do causal concepts arise
which is to say we look at the role that
those concepts play in an internal
inferential network
that's linked to perception at one end
and to action at another
so an agent
that is an agent like this that's
coupled to the environment by sensors
and actuators and it's getting
macroscopic information
we'll be interested in how
in knowing how what it does
affects what it sees
in causal concepts
will be defined both by their
connections to perception and to action
and the sciences that are relevant to
studying causal concepts now looking not
at the world but looking at the agent
and the way that her causal concepts are
nested in her internal economy the
sciences that are relevant to study that
are psychology cognitive science and
there's just a wealth of fascinating
work on causal cognition and learning on
the development of causal ideas on their
role in inference decision and action
and moral judgment
so if we step back
and we take a kind of cross-section
of the world ordered by scale and we
look at the layers of structure
from the microscopic all the way up to
the macroscopic up to the level of the
human being interacting with the
macroscopic environment
the picture that's sort of coming into
focus
looks something like this
the bottom layer there's the geometry of
space-time which in a classical setting
imposes or embodies constraints on the
causal connectability of the events and
by that i mean their connectability by
causal processes okay there's the matter
content
and there's the temporally symmetric
microscopic laws that tell us how
the matter in one volume of space-time
affects the matter in another volume of
space-time or how the state of the world
at one time relates to it stated another
and then there's the emergent
macroscopic asymmetries
and the macroscopic asymmetries arise
remember because of the low entropy
boundary condition at one end of the
universe
the macroscopic asymmetries in their
turn support the emergence of creatures
that use information to guide behavior
because of the way that the macroscopic
asymmetries
allow the present state of the world to
contain records information makes the
macroscopic states work rich with
information that agents can use
eventually those agents get complex
enough that they do something that we
would recognize as thinking and by the
time we get to creatures like us
thinking is causal from stem
to stern
now while there's not much that's known
and various points of dispute the sketch
that i just gave is robust with respect
to most of the emerging details
and notice how much it transforms both
our understanding of causation
and our understanding of ourselves is
very different from anything that we
might that might have come out of simply
reflection on the concept of cause no
single part of this story is the story
of what causes are
but i think that once all of the pieces
are assembled there's no further
question no story about the metaphysics
of causation that needs to be answered
there are two questions that
philosophers always want to ask about
causes they want to ask
are causes inside or outside the head
are they part of the mind independent
fabric of reality or are they in the eye
of the observer and they want to ask
where does the asymmetry come from
to take the second one first
we've just seen a rather complex answer
to the source of the asymmetry
what we saw was that there's not a
single asymmetry but rather a couple of
related asymmetries there's a
thermodynamic gradient created by low
entropy state of the universe which
creates a macroscopic asymmetry that in
its turn supports the emergence of
information gathering and utilizing
systems when such systems get
sufficiently complex information and
gathering and utilization takes the form
of conceptual activity
creatures like this develop causal
concepts with a built-in asymmetry that
reflects an asymmetry in their practical
and
relationship to the world
so while there's no fundamental
asymmetric relation of determination in
physics for creatures like us who couple
to the macroscopic structure of the
world the fact that information flows
from from the past and causal
information runs into the future is a
fundamental informative feature of our
experience and one that frames every
aspect of our thoughtful engagement with
the world and one that's built into all
of our concepts
now on the question
of whether causes are inside or outside
the head
the right thing to say is partly inside
and partly outside for the reasons that
i just gave
pre-scientific ideas about causation
aren't really i think articulated enough
to single out one part of this layered
structure that leads from microscopic
processes all the way up to the coupled
interaction between agent environment
in which causal thinking has its home as
where the causes are
scientifically there's no uniform usage
physicists will speak of spatial
temporal geometry is encoding causal
structure but when biologists talk about
causal structure they mean something
much
higher in that stratigraphic hierarchy
when ordinary people talk about
causation they invoke ideas closely
associated with the phenomenology of
pushing and pulling something with a
sort of quasi-muscular notion of
compulsion in mind
we can see how all of these ideas arise
and how they relate to one another and i
don't really see that there's a factual
question to be settled about which of
them captures the essence of causation
or about which point at which point in
that hierarchy we finally really have
causes
now notice
that this kind of account is different
from what we might think of as the
prototypical philosophical analysis of a
concept
and it's characteristic of the way in
which we get a scientific account
of um of a notion what one of those
notions that play a central role in
mediating our practical and epistemic
interaction with the world
other notions that are like this i think
are probability
and um information to some extent okay
there's an external component that is
the infrastructure in the environment
that agents use as strategic pathways to
bringing about ends
and there's also an internal component
an account of the content of causal
concepts understood partly in terms of
their role
in
in an internal inferential network
and a big part
of understanding what causation is is
fitting those pieces together
it's saying how agents with the kind of
information that we have and our
practical capacities for intervention in
a world that is objectively structured
like ours
how those agents develop and use causal
ideas
so there are two philosophically i'm
almost done the two philosophically
important aspects of the account
one is that it secures the objectivity
of causal relations making them apt
objects for scientific study and the
second is that it's a really good
antidote to reifying causal relations as
compulsive asymmetric relations between
local events
built right into the fundamental fabric
of the world
there are causal pathways written into
the fabric of the world but those
pathways are neither asymmetric nor
compulsive
we see i think that the complete account
of the metaphysics of causation is given
by the facts about our world and about
our position in it that support the
acquisition and the use of causal
concepts and that account does not treat
causal relationships as asymmetric pushy
relations of dependence that are writ
into the fundamental fabric of the world
but it makes causal relations objective
in all of the ways that should matter to
science it makes perfect sense to think
of science as devoted to
as russell put it in his later years
discovering the causal skeleton
of the world
so i think of this kind of account as a
side on you
the sight on you brings into focus the
assemblage aside onto you because it
takes a kind of side on look at the at
the agent and it coupled to the world
and the processes that mediate its
interaction
now the side on view brings into focus
an assemblage of different structures
starting with geometry becoming
progressively more articulated by the
context and coming into sharp relief in
their distinctive role in practical
reasoning for situated agents
there are a number of well-defined
precise concepts as i said that can be
introduced to talk about structures at
different levels of this edifice for the
reasons that i gave i think no account
of causal concepts that doesn't bring
out their distinctive role in practical
reasoning
and the way in which causal concepts are
structured by that role can be complete
but but we can't talk about causal
structure
in the stripped-down sense that applies
just at the level of fundamental
geometry so that's the difference
between causal structure and causal
concept
at that level one thinks of space time
as encoding relations of causal
connectibility
one can talk about also causal structure
in a way that links it to physical
processes as in the tradition that leads
from
salmon through phil dao
one can also talk about causal structure
in a way that connects it to the kinds
of emergent pathways captured in dags or
one can talk about it in a way that ties
it to agency with all of the
articulation and inferential and
practical commitments that come from
being embedded in a whole network of
concepts these notions don't compete we
shouldn't insist on a single notion
that's going to serve all of these
purposes
each one of them is well defined and we
can see how causal notions become
increasingly structured increasingly
articulated as the setting
is enriched
is precisely because the notion i think
spans all of these levels from
fundamental geometry up through the
agent's strategic pathways
that it is so useful in linking them
together
as i said i think something similar can
be said of probability and information
it's precisely the level spanning
character of these notions that makes
them particularly well suited to
bridging the divide between purely
physical description and the structured
interface that the mind brings to its
understanding
of nature
okay
so the question about
another quick question and uh this is
really beautiful the side on view really
powerful
i was just wondering is there um any
ordering preferred ordering are this
like a hierarchy of ways of looking or
are these just um
is there an ordering in these um
so there is a physical ordering so if
one star so that's why i said if one
starts with physical structure ordered
by scale then at the bottom level
there's going to be geometry that is
sort of
you know you can characterize geometry
independently of the matter content and
then when you enrich it with the matter
content then you get like causal process
notions and then when you add a
thermodynamic gradient you get the
asymmetry so there's a sort of natural
physical ordering and as you add more to
the physical uh to the physical
description of the system you get
increasingly enriched notions of
causation so that's the way that i'm
picturing it right so it's just that the
agents are really what i um
um what i had a sort of question about
right whether these agents um you could
have some conception of the agents
even as you look at the connectability
right so you may have some
notion of um
agency which you know stands to be
verified and consolidated but i was just
curious about that but okay so you're
putting your finger on something that um
it would take uh i mentioned in passing
and it would take a good deal more
to
[Music]
sort of articulate in a convincing way
but the way that i think about it is
that it's actually the thermodynamic
gradient and the fact that the
thermodynamic gradient makes the
macroscopic structure of the world rich
with information that explains the
emergence of agents in evolutionary
terms so if you think that what agents
are is by their nature so to speak what
they're designed to do
is be information gathering and
utilizing
creatures
then in a world where there's no
thermodynamic gradient there's going to
be no agents
so agents were designed and selected
because of the opportunities for
information gathering and use that's
provided by the thermodynamic gradient
they arise so to speak to take advantage
of those opportunities and then that in
its turn explains why
um agents like us
are
our senses are coupled to the
macroscopic
um structure of the world so sometimes
people
i know we're almost at time so i'll be
i'll say this quickly and maybe we can
um
talk about it more but i think what's
what um people sometimes speak as when
you say that really the asymmetry arises
with the thermodynamic gradient and it's
a macroscopic
coarse graining imposed by the
thermodynamic gradient that gives rise
to the asymmetry they sometimes say oh
so it's just an artifact of the fact
that we happen to have senses that parse
the world that see in a coarse-grained
way and i think the right direction of
that you know when you see the whole
assemblage in the way that i've sketched
it the right way to see the direction of
explanation is
we see in macroscopic terms because
that's where the um
the opportunities for
gathering and using information
yeah
thanks thanks yeah and i mean we can
continue this offline i i get what you
were um um good okay i'm almost done so
i'll i'll end quickly then so the
general idea and this is just a
concluding um to bring it back around
the general idea is that the question
the question of how causation arises in
the structure of the cosmos
has been a live one since russell
observed that it appears to have
disappeared from the fundamental level
of physical description so in 2003
hartree field called this
quote the central problem in the
metaphysics of causation
and it's a question that's animated a
good deal of
recent discussion
um in in philosophy
i transformed that question into the
question of how causation arises of the
question of how causation arises into
the question of how causal thinking and
the structures that support causal
thinking arise and then assembled the
pieces of of what we have learned about
causation in the last 20 or 30 years
into the outline of an answer to those
questions and suggested that once those
questions are answered there's no
specifically metaphysical question about
causation that remains so this sort of
naturalist this is a kind of
naturalistic pragmatism that seems to me
the only sensible way
and only sensible way to approach
ontological questions whether it's a
question of what cows are what causation
is or what democracy is
thank you
great um thank you so much and for this
really uh thought provoking and um
sort of exquisite explanation i mean
there are obviously really deep
foundational questions and it's really
sort of testimony to
your clarity that you touched upon many
of them so i would like to give a big
round of applause and i see a lot of
people um
have the clap emoji on so at least i
wanted to give you an auditory class
thank you so much so i think we'll open
up for questions now
so um i noticed there's a question uh
from alexander meehan so
he says i noticed that in the structure
a different level slide that you showed
one thing that wasn't on the list was a
statistical mechanical probability
distribution over microstates
this looks essential to the albert
picture but you don't seem specially
wedded to his
precise account
so the question is to what extent do you
think introducing non-dynamical chance
is essential for giving an account of
emergent causation
um i think it's essential and actually
what it the probability postulate was
meant to be the statistical mechanical
probability distribution and it's
essential to the whole picture
so sorry if that wasn't clear
great thanks for that clarification
and uh we have another question from
peter morgan who is asking are there
other orderings than scale that we could
have in mind for a side on view
systematic organizational organization
for example
ah yes absolutely um and that would be
natural in the biological context
yes i mean that's i absolutely
thanks um
are they um any other questions
oh great
uh so we have one from jenny uh who is
asking which role has causation in
quantum mechanics for you
okay
so
um
there are two questions you might be
asking one is whether the quantum mechan
whether quantum mechanics plays any role
in this story and the answer is no so
this this whole sort of hierarchy is um
sort of erected on an effectively the as
i told the pictures erected on a kind of
effectively classical level of
description
if you're asking well what does one say
about causation and quantum mechanics
huge open question i think you know if
and and
you know
there are different ways that one can
answer it depending on how one
disambiguates um
the different notions of causation so if
you're asking are there causal processes
in quantum mechanics
um that is you know chains of
interactions
um
involving the
the um exchange of uh
conserved quantity um the answer is um
not on right now
not in space time is the answer to that
so
if you're asking are there um
uh sort of inter interventionist notions
of cause of causation that are
applicable in quantum mechanics the
answer is yes and in fact some people
have used interventionist notions to
argue that quantum mechanics almost by
its nature involves retrocausality so
you take the quantum formalism you ask
yourself what happens if i intervene
here and you see causal relations under
certain conditions running into the past
so
big open question really interesting
question and i think there's a number of
different questions that one can ask but
it's not
one that played any role um in the story
that i told
so um
we have a question uh sort of a
clarification request from paul so is
causation structure asymmetric at the
microscopic level
uh if you're saying it is not how that
how could that be given the low entropy
state that we started from
at the macro it absolutely is um
asymmetric so again you know there was
some
i was sort of trying to assemble the big
pieces so i didn't go into details of
each of the little ones and when i did
it wasn't clear enough but here's the
idea
so you start the that i'm going to use
kind of the albert account
though you can make twiddles to the
albert account if you object to the
particular form that he has of the past
hypothesis or the probability postulate
just clear us to say it in that setting
here's the idea you assume low entropy
boundary condition you take the present
survivable macrostructure of the world
and you ask what and you assume a
probability positive
and you ask what happens if i intervene
on a kind of on my environment of in in
the kind of way that we think of
normally when we're talking about the
sorts of manipulations that embedded
agents like us can make
how do you answer that question in the
statistical mechanical framework you
take the probability distribution you
evolve at first pass to find out whether
the intervention makes a difference to
the past and then you evolve it forward
to find out whether the intervention
makes a difference to the future when
you evolve it backwards if you're
conditionalizing on a low entropy state
in the past
you will get the results that it makes
no difference to any event of which
there is a macroscopic record and if you
think about it for like a minute and a
half you'll find out that includes
pretty much
everything that we could form any sort
of belief about there's at least
potentially a macroscopic record of some
kind about whether or not the event took
place if you do that in the forward
direction you say again you take the low
entropy boundary condition in the past
present survivable macrostate of the
world and you ask what happens if i
intervene on the environment so i step
in the sand
i build a house i dig a ditch and you
can and what you find when you when you
evolve the probability distribution
forward is pretty much what common sense
thinks
of
as the effects of
those kinds of interventions are the
ones that are assigned to high
probability by the probability
distribution
so that's the way that you get the
causal asymmetry out of the statistical
mechanical account
so uh then ken winkler has um has a
question that actually i also had the
same question which is can you say a bit
more about your naturalistic pragmatism
and your inclination to dispense with
more traditional forms of philosophical
analysis perhaps by illustrating how it
might be applied to one of the cases
that you mentioned as you concluded
this is the problem with giving a talk
where you say too much so that's a huge
question um but i'll say for example
with information so wait let me say a
little bit um
the kind of naturalistic
pragmatism is not a conceptual analysis
of these notions so what it does is it
takes as it's targeted
of explanation
you know why would agents like us have
developed concepts like that what are
the external
um what are the external structures that
support the application of those
concepts and how do those concepts
figure in the internal economy of the
agent so think about something like
information
this is a notion that's been you know
sort of it gets used a lot in physics
and it's one of these notions that's um
contested in the way that causation is
because many people will say look you're
applying causal notions to
the physical explanation but the notion
of sorry then
the notion of information to physical
explanation but information isn't
something that we can define directly in
causal terms it's intentionally laid and
it's got all of these associations that
come from the use of language and so on
and what i want to say in the case like
that is well
just like the case of causation you know
we can we can
start at the fundamental level of um of
just physical description before we have
the introduction of agents or anything
like that with notions of information
that are stripped down and that we can
introduce in those stripped-down ways
that play a role in in low-level
description making sure that we're not
importing associations
and then as we add matter and we add you
know um ultimate and we add evolution we
add biology and we add ultimately um
agents that are not just using
information to guide behavior not not
only
okay wait let me back up there's a
crucial point there's a crucial step in
the case of information that's worth
pausing to dwell on
when we're starting to talk about um
systems that were evolutionarily
designed we do get more structure in
that can give rise to that can impose a
little bit more articulation on the
notion of of information so now we have
slightly richer notion and then we start
getting
systems that are using information in
more and more sophisticated ways
ultimately agents that are introducing
concepts and inferences and again it
gets more articulated till finally we
have something that's rich enough to be
applied to
linguistic interactions so that's that's
another
very schematic sketch of the kind of
thing that i have in mind and at no
point do you say you know this is what
information is information is purely
physical or or information is purely
mental is something that plays a role at
different levels of that hierarchy
great um
i think
peter morgan
comments so crudely put does a side on
view
say that the past hypothesis could be
true
or false as a global statement about all
length or other scales
provided for example all creatures like
us start from the same direction in time
with no memory
i have not so i'm going to read the
question again because i'm not sure
anything
for the past hypothesis could be true or
false as a global statement
yes so the past hypothesis though is a
statement
about uh the macro state of the world so
it says that the the
the universe started
in some microstate
that has low entropy that is that is a
member of a low entropy macro state when
the
thermodynamic core screening is
applied so it's by its nature in a way
it classifies the early microstate of
the world by a reference to the
thermodynamic core screening
does that
okay peter does that
yeah i guess he was referring back to
carlos talk where he the focus was like
on memory right yeah
right so what i've been talking about
uh as
the capacity of the universe to bear
information about its past state that's
what carla was talking about when he
talked about memory
so
and that depends
entirely on
the
the low entropy initial condition of the
universe
uh just waiting to see if
there are
any further questions
just give
give people a minute um
so um
i don't see any pressing questions but
um anyway um we could uh thank you so
much
we can wrap up today and you know if
there are any questions uh you know we
can uh hold on to them for our
discussion session uh tomorrow afternoon
at the same time
3 p.m uh with uh jim uh woodward as the
conversant and discussant
with jannan so
thank you so much everyone for attending
and a special thank you to janan for a
wonderful inspiring talk
thank you for coming and thank you for
having me
bye